merci jean françois bien maintenant là
la parole est à la salle ya une question
la droite une au fond bonjour on me
demande de me soumettre à la
vidéoprotection je me le sommet bien
volontiers bonjour à tous mathieu singer
je suis élu dans le 2e arrondissement
donc dans l'équipe de valérie montandon
et j'ai une question donc sur la salle
de shoot puisque effectivement c'est une
question compliquée et qui relève aussi
de la loi puisque avant les années 70 on
dépend des d'une loi de 1916 où il était
permis de consommer enfin il était la
répression de la consommation des
stupéfiants n'était faite que lorsque le
stupéfiant était consommée dans la
société
chez soi il n'y avait pas de problème
entre temps l'héroïne est arrivé
entre-temps mai 68 est passée par là
entre temps l'augmentation des
consommations est devenue problématique
le législateur est intervenu
sauf que le législateur a distingué au
niveau de l'usager enfin l'usagé est
devenu à la fois un délinquant est à la
fois un patient et là on a un vrai sujet
parce que si les patients les médecins
doivent doivent s'en occuper aujourd'hui
les médecins entre la sécurité sociale
qui qui leur tombent dessus parce qu'ils
prescrivent trop et entre les
désertification médicale et ils n'ont
pas le temps et la volonté de s'occuper
des toxicomanes donc c'est la raison de
ces salles de shoot on peut comprendre
qu'il y ait ces salles de shoot
maintenant leur implantation pose
problème je n'ai pas envie que
l'expérimentation réussi c'est
qu'ensuite elles viennent dans toutes
les gares comme la gare de lyon pour mon
arrondissement
donc ma question ce serait plutôt est ce
que ce n'est pas au législateur
d'intervenir
deborah pavlik disait qu'il fallait
effectivement accompagné ces toxicomanes
effectivement c'est des personnes en
souffrance
la dépendance est une souffrance mais en
même temps la loi est là aussi pour
accompagnées parfois de manière un peu
coercitives pour avec des obligations de
soins est ce que ça ne serait pas au
législateur et donc le rôle des
républicains de proposer une législation
pour pour améliorer cette ce système je
vous remercie
merci déborah
oui vous avez tout à fait raison je sais
pas vous êtes partis sur le constat sur
le d'être très beau rappel de
l'évolution législative sur sur la sur
la question moi je vais aller beaucoup
plus loin loin que vous sur le sujet je
suis pas d'accord quand vous dites que
ça peut être une expérimentation qui va
réussir
moi j'y suis opposé sur le principe même
de cette ouverture pas par idéologie
mais par simple pragmatisme comme j'ai
exposé tout à l'heure il faut pas
oublier par ailleurs qu'à partir du
moment où va ouvrir ces salles de shoot
on aura une dépénalisation de fait des
drogues
il est d'ailleurs bien précisé dans
l'article 9 du projet loi santé qui met
en place l'expérimentation que les
détenteurs de stupéfiants dès lors
qu'ils seront dans le périmètre de la
salle de shoot ne pourront pas être ni
aux contrôles ennemis appréhender donc
on arrive bien à l'instauration d'une
zone de non droit qui est encore entouré
d'un véritable flou artistique puisque
rien n'est précisé en la matière on sait
pas par exemple comment ça va se passer
quand la personne va prendre les
transports si elles sortent du métro à
gare du nord pour ensuite se rendre à la
salle de shoot et qu'ils allaient
contrôler la gare du nord qu'est ce qui
se passe
elle sera dans un périmètre qui sera un
périmètre de proximité mais pas
exactement à côté de la salle de shoot
moi je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui là dessus et eux mêmes ne le
savent pas pour le moment donc le mon
opposition à les deux principes de toute
façon il ne peut pas y avoir ouvert
tueur de salles de shoot aujourd'hui en
tout cas nous on continuera et je compte
beaucoup là dessus sur frédéric pour
comporte ce combat de manière à ce qu'il
n'y a pas d'ouverture de salles de shoot
et surtout pas autour de la gare du nord
autre question madame ma question
concerne la sécurité telles que j'ai pu
constater qu'elle avait été renforcée
lors du plan vigipirate
on a vu apparaître des militaires et des
forces de l'ordre que je ne saurais pas
désigner de façon précise avec des armes
impressionnante
la seule chose c'est que j'ai entendu
que ces armes n'était pas doté afin que
ces personnes n'avaient pas de munitions
et n'avait pas le droit de tirer alors
je voudrais oui j'entends légende
urbaine je voudrais savoir ce qu'il en
est précisément il avait avancé le sens
dole et les policiers donc vous avez des
militaires je serai là par l'agent
françois masque au sein des policiers
qui sont soit des compagnies américaines
de sécurité soit des policiers locaux
comme les deux qui étaient devant le
siège de répliquer 1 ce matin ils sont
armés et sont armés d'un pistolet
automatique individuelle et ils ont
également des pistes mitrailleur beretta
et ses armes sont approvisionnés avec
des munitions et ils ont le droit de
tirer dans les conditions normales qui
sont celles de la légitime défense
c'est à dire que ils pourront tirer pour
se défendre s'ils étaient attaqués
en ce concerne les militaires
jean-françois ils ont il en va de même
pour les militaires désormais mais je
sais pas où vous êtes madame 1 quand
vous avez parlé au fond d'accord est la
part dont je vous avais pas vu vous
étiez dans dans l'ombre mais quand je
vous disais tout à l'heure on est sur
une légitimité mais en particulier en
matière de l'ucim différence qui est
beaucoup plus floue pour les forces
armées
c'est bien ce qui pose aujourd'hui le
problème de l'emploi des forces sur le
territoire sur le territoire français
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous avons affaire à
des soldats qui sont très solides
mentalement parlant psychologiquement
parlant
et qui je croise d'ailleurs cette à nice
il ya quelques mois on réagit
remarquablement alors que l'un d'entre
eux étaient attaqués à coups de couteau
mais c'est vrai que en terme de légalité
nous sommes dans une sorte de flou
juridique qu'aujourd'hui encore le
gouvernement n'a pas réglé
nous sommes dans le même dispositif que
frédéric rappelait c'est-à-dire fait
légitime défense mais la notion
digitimes défense pour un militaire n'a
pas véritablement de sens puisque vous
le savez quand ils sont en opération
extérieure et répondent tout autant à la
mission qu'il aurait donné mais aussi
aux lois qui régissent le pays dans
lequel ils interviennent quand qui a
encore un état qui régit des lois dans
les pays dans lesquels ils interviennent
donc on est exactement dans le même
dispositif avec du matériel beaucoup
plus lourd c'est du matériel de guerre
contrairement aux forces de police
intérieure donc avec vous imaginez bien
en cas d'utilisation des dégâts beaucoup
plus importants
quand la cible est touché tant mieux
quand il ya des dégâts collatéraux on
peut imaginer ce que ça peut donner
mais je tiens à dire encore une fois
corps au-delà de la problématique
technique que vous soulignez faut
rappeler la qualité de celles et ceux
qui défendent le territoire aujourd'hui
que ce soit les policiers que ce soit
les soldats dans un contexte je voulais
dits de grande tension sur les missions
qui leur sont demandées un soldat
aujourd'hui il fait tout autant de
l'opération sentinelle c'est à dire
qu'il est devant un incident sensible
pour le défendre
mais quelques semaines plus tard
quelques semaines plus tard il peut être
projeté au sahel en jordanie aux émirats
arabes unis ou pour alors dans une
mesure bien moindre bien sûr nos pilotes
en tout cas l'armée de l'air peut l'être
également mais on leur demande
effectivement moins des forces et
surtout les forces théâtre qui sont
sollicités mais ils font les deux c'est
un choix du gouvernement
aujourd'hui le chef d'état major de
l'armée de terre accepte ce double
engagement mais je crains que sur la
durée cela ne soit pas tenable pour
toutes les raisons que j'ai évoquées
préparation
transformation quand il s'agit de
transformer des régiments vers les faire
progresser
mais aussi fatigue puis quand vous
demandez un soldat qui a une famille de
partir sur plusieurs sites plusieurs
fois par an ça pose des problèmes y
compris des problèmes familiaux donc le
type est pas bien dans sa tête et ça
peut dégénérer
donc on a un vrai souci aujourd'hui de
doctrine d'emploi des forces
l'utilisation des armes de guerre sur
sur le sol français qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas réglés merci jean françois une
autre question
oui la rumba
oui parlement de 120 à propos de
politique pénale vous avez tous entendu
ce que madame taubira pour l'appeler par
son nom a suggéré qu'elle envisageait
une escorte pour le permissionnaire de
sortie il paraît que c'était hyper x est
inenvisageable on voit aujourd'hui je
veux apporter un témoignage personnel
historique
il ya une vingtaine d'années j'ai un
neveu qui est mort tragiquement dans un
accident de voiture et à ses obsèques
nous avons tous eu la surprise il
n'avait pas que de gaulle fréquentation
de voir que et ses camarades étaient
présents avec deux gendarmes et c'était
un petit délinquant et s'était même pas
pour la mort de sa famille donc pourquoi
ce qui était possible courant il ya
vingt ans les plus possible aujourd'hui
alors faites d'abord c'est c'est
toujours possible
c'est là que madame taubira réinvente
quelque chose qui existe déjà mais il
est impossible de faire encadrer la
totalité des permissions de sortie et
d'ailleurs le sujet s'est pas attardé
sur une sortie le sujet ces actions la
donne il n'est pas anormal que en fin de
peine des délinquants bénéficient d'une
permission de sortie à partir du moment
où on pense qu'ils ne présentent pas de
grands risques dans la sphère qui a fait
que j'ai un policier qui a perdu la vie
nous avons quelqu'un qui est un
multirécidiviste il a été a hérité 24 x
est un homme violent
il a été arrêté pour des vols à main
armée c'est un homme donc qui possèdent
des armes qui s'est radicalisée en
prison et salades mise en substance hier
le sait et malgré tout on lui donne une
permission de sortie
il ne réintègre pas il s'évade donc
techniquement
puis il va monter sur un nouveau
braquage et là il sera mené à après un
échange de coups de feu avec la police a
tué un policier
c'est ça dont nous ne voulons pas bien
sûr il faut que les gens puissent avoir
une permission de sortie
bien sûr il faut qu'ils aient déjà
aménagement de peine
bien sûr le cas échéant pour aller
enterrer son père ou sa mère ce
quelqu'un est dangereux et bien ma foi
ont pu dans une permission de sortie et
le faire garder mais fondamentalement ce
dont nous ne voulons plus c'est que des
gens dangereux sorte et fasse prendre
des risques complètement irrationnel aux
citoyens aux policiers aux gendarmes une
autre question peut-être une dernière
question d'ailleurs maurice leblanc je
suis du 10e arrondissement donc
concernés par leurs salles de shoot bien
entendu et la propreté parce qu'ils vont
avec notre
mr est très favorable à cette initiative
or je ne trouvez vous pas que pour les
consommateurs il faudrait plutôt les
soigner parce que je considère qu'ils
sont dépendants donc malade relève plus
de la médecine
est-ce qu'il est très important ne
croyez vous pas qu'il faut lutter
d'abord contre les trafiquants contre
les dealers en partant du plus haut du
plus bas et j'ai été très surpris
d'apprendre que le sénat dont nous
sommes auxquelles nous sommes majeurs
dans lequel pardon nous sommes
majoritaires avaient voté une
expérimentation sur ces salles de shoot
en ce qui concerne la sécurité ne croyez
vous pas que tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
réponse pénale tant qu'il n'y aura pas
une justice qui cautionnent ce que nos
merveilleuses choses que font nos forces
on ne pourra pas être dissuasif et pour
cela ne faudrait-il pas que les parquets
poursuivre systématiquement et que les
juges appliquent le code pénal
merci merci monsieur c'est plus
d'ailleurs un témoignage une question
puisque vous le savez nous sommes nous
l'avons dit redit régulièrement tout à
fait opposés à l'ouverture de la salle
de shoot mais merci pour votre
témoignage
une autre question oui au deuxième rang
la merci bonjour on a dit amour ce quota
national d'intégration je voulais poser
une question à hughes dont l'exposé a
été très pertinent et très riche donc
vous parliez de de guerre de guerre
totale que les barbares nous
nous ont déclaré que de ce fait nous
devrions nous aussi être davantage
mobilisés alors cèdre certes notre
police doit être mobilisée et doit aussi
disposer de tous les moyens humains et
financiers nécessaires mais je pense
aussi que la société civile est en
l'occurrence les représentants de
l'islam de france aujourd'hui doit aussi
se poser des questions et de aussi
prendre ses responsabilités dans le sens
aujourd'hui on a une instance qui est
plus ou moins représentative qui est le
cfcm qui a été vidée de sa substance
parole par la gauche je pense qu'il est
vraiment urgent que cette instance soit
productrice d'un contre-discours qui qui
vient en fait en contradiction avec les
discours de haine et de violence qui
sont véhiculées par les islamistes et
rien encore aujourd'hui n'a été fait je
suis très attaché à la laïcité est donc
à la séparation entre entre l'église et
la chose et la chose publique
je je me pose la question de savoir s'il
n'est pas de la responsabilité aussi de
l'état de 2 je sais pas moi de faire une
injonction des grosses guillemets 1,7
ces représentations enfin ses
représentants de l'islam de france pour
justement contrer ce discours et
prévenir peut-être le basculement de nos
jeunes dans dans la radicalité alors
aujourd'hui à des sites internet enfin
il ya un site internet qui a été mis en
place par le gouvernement stoppe
djihadisme qui fait beaucoup rire
je pense que c'est fin c'est aussi de la
responsabilité voilà des musulmans de
france 2 de se mobiliser de dire que non
l'islam c'est pas ça et
et voilà c'était une des questions que
je me posais merci beaucoup
oui en quelques secondes simplement vous
avez raison là je crois que le problème
s'étend qu'on ne
on n'acceptera pas de dire qu'il y a un
lien ténu entre le terrorisme islamiste
et l'islam radical
on n'arrivera pas à ce que vous
souhaitez tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui le discours des institutions
religieuses et le discours du
gouvernement c'est de dire le terrorisme
islamiste n'a rien à voir avec l'islam
bien sûr que bien sûr que ça n'a rien à
voir mais il y a un lien quand même et
tant qu'on n'arrive pas à identifier et
à s'attaquer à ce lien on n'arrivera pas
à résoudre la question donc il faut
cesser de dire ça n'a rien à voir dire
c'est de la déviance c'est de la
perversion mais moi acteurs de l'islam
en france
j'ai une responsabilité et c'est à moi
de mener le combat à mon niveau contre
le radicalisme et à faire la chasse à
cette passerelle que constitue le
salafisme radical vers le terrorisme
je crois que tous les groupes
terroristes aujourd'hui sont des gros
salafistes voilà et en france nous avons
beaucoup salafisme donc il faut bien
évidemment les contrer et puis
simplement vous parlez du d'internet
j'en ai pour deux secondes
moi je crois que nous devons déployer
des véritables moyens de guerre
technologique de la cyberguerre pour
contrer le terrorisme 2.0 et on ne le
fait pas aujourd'hui suffisamment merci
je donne la parole aux sénateurs charon
qui voudrait dire quelques mots sur les
salles de shoot et le ciel à vous avez
tout à fait raison
en commission des affaires sociales nous
républicain avons été mis en minorité
avec madame jouanno et ses amis de lui
des ics était pour l'expérience de
salles de shoot dans la rue un
amendement est donc passé faisant que
les salles de shoot aille au moins dans
un hôpital à lariboisière
mais nous le sénateur dominati et moi
même avons refusé
solidaire du conseil de paris et contre
à tout prix les salles de shoot de voter
ce texte
donc les titres c'est vrai son réducteur
à savoir le sénat autorise sajoo c'est
pas que tu as fait ça autorise à
l'hôpital mais même nous sommes contre
ça et philippe dominati et moi n'avons
pas voté ce texte
mais vous avez raison de le rappeler
merci bien
pierre lellouche pour l'assemblée
nationale
un point d'information aussi pour nos
adhérents et pour tout le monde sait que
effectivement j'ai vu cet incident au
sénat je veux simplement dire qu'elle a
semblé on a été au contraire
extraordinairement combatif et qu'on a
tenu même des points de presse pour
expliquer en faisant venir d'ailleurs
des victimes de ces expérimentations
parce que malheureusement dans un
certain nombre de pays je pense à
l'espagne la suisse zurich y avait il ya
des jardins publics y ont été
transformés en lieux de en lieu de shoot
public on s'est aperçu que c'est
catastrophique y compris pour pour pour
les addicts qui sont venus témoigner
devant les journalistes à l'assemblée
nationale au mois d'avril année dernier
au moment où madame touran présenter son
projet de loi sur l'expérimentation
donc je sais que nos gars en tenue au
sénat mais nous on a aussi beaucoup
battus à l'assemblée c'est celle merci
pierre